不能弄臉我花過最重的心思
就是在我的頭髮上
頭刪髮變成現在這種水光髮
我真的有很多很多的心得要分享
之前兩光是在禮髮店做護理
就花了不想我會說
那些真的學到了很多很多
有那麼小技巧
確認是該和我今天都分享了
首先我發現
頭髮說髮模的手髮很重要
就是在外面做完護理頭髮
就跟頭髮一樣
又是很髮有光紫
我把頭髮長進來
我來自己
就感覺非常苦痛
像買的髮夾或一樣
後來才知道是這個手髮很重要
我現在的這個手髮
我覺得我都可以去幫護髮的脫女了
首先喜歡頭髮
我已經帶你家頭髮上多女的水分
頭髮髮髮持在不會低水
就是失忍的狀態
這一點是很容易被護士到
所以我們之前上的護髮塗完髮
我其實都是被洗濕過的
很多一樣程內也沒有被頭髮吃進去
接著哪一把頭髮還是把身的頭髮
給身散開來
這一步就可以防止頭髮都積壓在一起
然後我們塗護髮長的時候
就只要表面這一層的腹感
然後長在裡面的頭髮
就是沒有被罩到
五碗了
腹髮長的腹之後
再用這種盤手
再屬於被拒保每一個髮絲
都被這個腹髮長平腹感爆
然後可以用手劇按摩一下
加速吸收
過個幾分鐘之後就可以去洗澡
這套流程相當是把腹髮長的效果最大化
有最開始的五十分
要受到幾五十分
雖然它的時間比明一下要長
因為那次出來的效果真的很矩
那麼可以洗髮
然後就是水
只正是理用的髮
我還要重量的
做五糊塘浪
加那邊水
這就超好
所以我在那邊喜歡頭
就算不用護髮長體頭髮
都是很涉髮
有種水光感
但是在深圳中的不行
然後我每天輕輕
可能沒有髮
我頭髮也還涉毛毛髮
後來的頭你告訴我
這個水質的原因
我自然是令人避兀
會讓髮治變差
我們家有髮精神經濟
所以我就把髮殺放進之後
可以持綠的
然後就放在我的頭髮
確實沒有之前那麼容易乾瘦
掉頭髮的情況有少了很多
身上你覺得沒有那麼乾的洗完澡
什麼流的
最後一點就是吹頭髮
大車頭髮身就是這樣
躲吹吹又吹
完全沒有什麼手髮
但是這樣
換吹吹吹出頭髮很容易瘦毛
後來我發現所有你髮
使他很在吹頭髮的時候
都會給客人用這種點解頭
他能讓車鬆激吹吹的髮
對他的激蹤力能夠更好的去做造型
而且吹頭髮的時候
一定要從髮跟往髮尾去帶
一直重復一個方向
這樣可以讓頭髮的毛臉騙
更好的是避免
吹出來的頭髮
他是不是總身不毛髮過大解的頭髮